This is one of the websites that we run,
and it's currently getting over 888 AI
overviews. It's ranking for 87 ChatGPT
mentions. In AI search mode, we're
getting over 294
responses. 123 of those pages are
indexed. On Gemini, about 16.
Perplexity, 128. Copilot, 33. And Grok,
101. And on AIO search query, 72. And in
addition to that, as you can see, this
website gets over 47,000 organic traffic
per month and ranks for over 7,000
keywords. So, if you want to know how to
get cited in AI search, how to get more
brand mentions in AI search, here are
five steps that you can do today to get
more AI search mention. Number one is
first do an audit to see where you are
on AI search. So, let's say you're a
plumbing company in a specific local
area. I would search up things like,
"What are the best plumbing companies in
my local area?" That's one of the main
uh search queries that you can search up
on Perplexity, ChatGPT, on Google, on
any place AI search is. Right? So, we
want to search up, and then we want to
pull all of that information. So, I'm
going to search it up, and I'm going to
see which websites are being cited more
often than not. So, I'm going to open up
the links to see the actual um
the actual articles that are being
mentioned by AI. So, we see one website
here. We see another website here.
Right? So, we're going to just open this
up, and this is all going to be for the
same search query. So, top tips on how
to choose plumbing companies in Toronto.
So, I just want to repeat this process
and open as many of these sources that
AI is already um citing.
So again, this is just for Perplexity,
but I'm going to do the same thing and
head over to ChatGPT.
I'm going to tell it to use the web
mode, and again, it's going to uh do the
same research.
And again, head over to Google. I'm
going search that up on Google and we
should get the AI overview mode here. So
again, we're going to take a look to see
which websites are showing up. So again,
we see some of these websites are going
to be duplicate, but this is really,
really good
signals that we need to see what these
websites are doing to get ranked. So
once I found a list of websites, what
I'm going to do is I'm going to copy
over all of this content from all of
these different sites. So I'm going to
copy over the content that we got from
this
better website, the second one as well.
And then we're going to take it over to
ChatGPT for a specific prompt. So I'm
just going to copy over all of the
information of the websites that we
found.
We're going to paste it into ChatGPT and
I'm going to give it this custom prompt.
If you want to get access to this
prompt, just comment AI search below and
I'll send it over to you. So once you've
entered in that audit, you'll then get
the results. So these are things that
your competitors are doing to rank for
specific keywords in AI search and
generally are more visible in AI search.
So number one, why these plumber pages
are being cited because the search query
matches the exact search intent. So the
search query is how to choose the right
plumber in Toronto. And for the first
website, Drainworks, they have that
exact H1 topic in their website. So we
see here at Drainworks, plumbers in
Toronto, how to choose the right
company. So they have a whole page
dedicated to that specific title and
it's direct, right? As you can see, it's
direct. It directly integrated that
keyword into the actual article. For AY
Plumber, they did some something
similar, very direct title, how to
choose a plumber and for Dr. Pipe. So
this matters because AI system likes
extractable pages. The more the page
looks like a clean answer to the
question, it's easier to site. So simple
is better, easier to extract is better
when it comes to writing your AI
content. So next, it generally tells you
why these websites are more strong or
why they are more likely
to get cited, or have higher AI site
visibility. So, So, next the audit will
tell you why these websites are overall
stronger, and why why they're actually
getting more AI search visibility, and
getting cited more often by AI. So, why
Dreamworks is strong because it has the
best signal density. So, if I look at
Dreamworks the website, we can see here
that right off the bat we can notice
that they have a lot of embedded awards
or accolades or accolades that they've
gotten, and that is a direct trust
signal and trust factor that AI will see
because they want to see that other
places are mentioning you, or you've won
awards for certain things, and that is a
huge huge ranking factor of getting
cited by AI. So, then it tells you
again, it's going to go through each one
of those websites and tell you why it's
good, what you need to do um in order to
get shown by AI. So, again, it's going
to tell you directly what you need to do
as a website in order to get cited for
these specific search terms. Now, keep
in mind that this is only one search
term, so you can repeat this for as many
relevant and as many
long-tail key terms for your specific
niche. And below that, we're going to
get an AI / geo article brief, and this
is for specifically that keyword, how to
choose the right plumber in Toronto. So,
you can simply go ahead and copy this
over, and now I prefer to use Word
Rocket. Word Rocket is hands-down the
best geo writing tool in the market. So,
instead of you having to pre-prompt the
AI to tell it what to do to write the
content based upon your brand, you can
sign up for Word Rocket, set up your
brand guide, and then just simply go
ahead and in additional context, we're
going to throw in
our um brief that we got back. So, we're
going to take over the Then we're going
to take the target keyword, we're going
to paste it in here. We're going to
paste it in as the web search term, and
paste it in as a target keyword. We're
going to leave the settings as it is. As
I mentioned, you can toggle on brand
voice and use your own brand voice, so
it's going to speak in your own specific
tone. You can toggle on internal links
as well, so it's going to use internal
linking. And I recommend leaving on
geo-optimization.
Choose as many images as you like, and
click generate SEO content, and your
article will get generated. So, step one
is do an audit, step two is read your
audit, and see what content gap
opportunities there are, and what you
need to do to increase your trust
signal. And step three is actually going
over and using a tool like Word Rocket
to write in your brand voice, write in a
geo-optimized format with custom images
embedded in your articles as well.
So, number four is just rinse and
repeat. You're going to want to do this
for as many keywords as you need within
your niche. And number five is AI trust
more what other people say about your
site than what you say about your site.
So, that's why brand mentions and
backlinks are still important. So, just
like Drain Works was able to put these
awards within their um website and have
these trucks trust signals, it's
important for you to also be able to do
this for your website as well. So, have
links to HomeStars if you can, Yelp, uh
BBB, or your Google verified reviews
that really, really helps
your trust signals as well. So, AI can
go out and see that your website is
being mentioned in
other places. So, it's more likely to
mention your website when someone
searches up your content. If you want to
get the prompts that I mentioned in
today's video, just comment below. And I
hope that you guys enjoyed today's one,
and I'll see you in the next video. Take
care.